[Music]
alex
is with us alex is in illinois
welcome to the dave ramsey show alex all
right thanks dave thanks for taking my
call
um my my financial situation is as
follows
i'm 25 years old to live at home with an
income just north of 200 000
i have 70 000 in a savings account and
no debt
besides the car that i purchased in
january which is the reason for my call
today
i purchased a car for 39 000
this past january but since then my
mother has
encountered some financial struggles as
her
alimony situation has dramatically
changed i want to help
her out more with expenses as i
mentioned i bought the car
in january for 39 000 and i'm now
getting
offers from dealers for approximately 32
000
and i owe 26 000
on the car you make 200 and you have 70
000 in the bank
that's correct won't be wrong with
paying it off
i'm sorry we'll be wrong just paying it
off
is that what you think i should do if
you like the car
i it actually it now that i've
it wouldn't hurt too bad getting
something different so i don't know if i
should sell it get something cheaper
pay it off be something i don't know why
you would need to you don't have any
bills
i don't need to financially how much are
you going to be giving your mother
um probably a couple thousand
a month okay for how long
um for the foreseeable future i
anticipate my income increasing yearly
um
but i like to keep on assisting as much
as i can
well that's admirable um how old is she
she is 70. 70.
correct okay i um
all right let's let's break these things
apart there's three things here i'm
dealing with
number one i got a 25 year old that
makes 200 000 a year living at home
i'm out of there number two you got a
car that you can afford it's less than
half your annual income and you have the
money to pay it off
pay it off number three you make 20 000
a year if you want to give your mom some
money you can do that
i do not want to set up a situation
where you do that in perpetuation
with her that's what you were thinking i
could wait to see your head moving hogan
yeah absolutely
alex what what is caused her financial
situation
to become tough like this
her ex-husband has gone into court and
decided to stop
paying alimony okay and you are
currently living with her right now
that's correct okay okay so how much
more alimony does he owe her
uh she his intention is to not owe her
anything
i didn't ask that i asked how long is he
supposed to pay her
that he's supposed to pay in perpetuity
okay
and so how much is she receiving from
him when he pays
approximately 15 000 a month
a month a month and she doesn't have any
money
no she does she does but then why does
she need money from you
well she she would never say that she
needed it but how long does
that how long has she been making
fifteen thousand dollars a month
only the last five to six years and has
no money to you don't know what she has
to show for it
you don't have any idea what her
financial condition is
um i know it's not
where she would like it to be she owns a
large house and plans on selling it um
and i i think that's where all of her
money's tied up alex i would say this my
friend
he you know you it's admiral do you want
to help your mom
the deal is that she's got to want to be
helped
um and you know this is going to boil
down to her taking control of her money
and i as dave said i the idea of you
signing on to give her two grand a month
for from now until kingdom come to me it
sounds like
that's a that's going to be a bad path
to take
uh if she wants to sit down and talk
with you or better yet i'd probably send
her to a financial coach
we have those that we've got trained
across the country uh but you need to
take control of your situation buddy
and i you know you pay off the car do
not lease anything i can't believe you
mentioned that as an option
absolutely not either pay off what you
have or sell it or buy something for
cash
but uh you know you've got a good income
you got opportunities ahead of you you
just need a plan
all right here's the thing okay
she got fifteen 15 000 a month for five
years
and did not put herself in good
financial condition
you cannot support that kind of behavior
you can support her make sure she has
food
but um this lady is used to living
pretty high on the hog
and um you're not her new sugar daddy
that is not a healthy relationship for
her
or for you if you need to help your mom
have food or help your mom have basic
shelter or help her through a
transitional time
or give her fifteen thousand dollars to
pay a lawyer
so that she goes and whips this guy's
butt and he does pay the alimony
all of that's fine uh but this
you know for the foreseeable future was
your answer
bad answer yeah not because you're not a
good guy
but because it's not good for her to
eat out of the pocket of her own son
after she hasn't handled fifteen
thousand dollars a month
well enough to be able to support
herself
i hope that wasn't unkind but i know
this is your mom i'm calling out
but she's been irresponsible at a
minimum
that's what we're hearing and so you've
you cannot plug
into this as a you know a perpetuation
iv into this and just be pouring your
life's blood into this
and it's very kind to you to help and
you make a lot of money and all that's
good
and you do really not need to live there
and really really really
yeah it's just one guy to another okay
there's a lot of crap there's a lot of
stuff
going on here in the psychology of this
and it's just gonna be really good for
you to be on your own
if you have some clear boundaries and
kindness and support of your mom
for with a little bit more distance yeah
and uh
and one of the things i'm gonna support
her in uh is to aggressively defeat
this attempt to stop alimony um
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go in there and
fight that and i'm gonna spend some
money on that
fifteen thousand dollars a year is worth
fighting about
a month i mean fifteen thousand dollars
a month yeah well i'm just trying to
yeah this i mean it's astronomical and
hundred sixty thousand dollars a year i
mean you gotta that you cannot just
you know let the guy win that battle so
if you spend some money on that fight
good yeah if you spend some money on
food good
pay off your car move out see the
problem is when you call in here you get
a full set of answers you don't just get
the answer to your question
that's right because these things all
work together to accomplish where you're
going to be as a man
in you know in just a few more years
you're already a man but i mean
as a 30 year old man making this kind of
money where are you going to be
that's right and the last thing you want
to do is put yourself in a co-dependent
situation
without any guard rails my friend so
alex i'm hope appreciate you calling in
and uh you got it you got more than you
bargained for but you
you got some life advice that can put
you on the right path you got a good
heart